do you think that women only like
actually that's a good one do you think
women only like double standards when or
complain about complain about double
standards when it doesn't benefit us
go ahead
like um for example sorry one more thing
like for example um we don't see women
complaining about men not getting into
bars for free or having to not pay for
or have free drinks that's a double
standard
yeah because for me personally i feel
like
like
i want to be as equal as a man is so if
you're in a club and you've seen 20
you've seen guys pay like whatever
entrance right and they say oh you don't
have to pay you're going to pay just
because you feel about equal standards
that's a cat i can't lie i'm not paying
you know what if i get it for free i'm
getting it for three bucks but if
they're telling me that i have to pay
i'm not going to be like oh get me in
for free do you know what i'm saying
yeah yeah i think when it's in a in a
setting like this yeah i think agreed i
think everyone is i'm the anomaly type
yeah but when it comes to friday night
and we're about to walk to the club i
think and like
we're at the back of the line talking
about oh it's going to be
x amount to get in and they're giving it
this one oh yeah come to the front
no girl like
girl
you choose like if a guy didn't open it
like do something like what's it called
what's that saying when something's dead
um
not romance it's like shiver always dead
right okay it's the society it should be
dead because everything's equal i'm a
king too you treat me like a kid yeah
right first date type of vibes i pay for
men
let the girls go yeah i've paid for a
date or two
uh yeah actually yeah i do i like to
five to one ratio huh yeah wait
elaborate
he plays five times i play once wait
wait wait somewhere away so you said you
paid for it but you're playing
no but i'm saying no but i'm saying like
i still like to pay i make money and i
think this is the whole like balance of
women
so he didn't like like you liked him for
being ugly and funny and then you when
he
no i've paid for dates four days you
felt some type of way though right
you're like no no no no i still put i'm
with a relationship like one day okay so
then would you pay for the second one
would you pay for the second one what
right after yeah i think it's still fair
like what i'm spending all my days like
say he's going for some [ __ ] like that
but you wanted to see him you can play
like one two three
you have but like it's not a normal
thing like you wouldn't let that run all
the way of course but that's like what
what
yeah exactly and that's that's right but
i think the point is like you still said
five dates to one it's not equal
no it's not but i'm still putting my
hand in my pocket where some women some
some women don't some women don't
you've met so don't be deflecting that
onto this conversation
that's not it's not reflecting that's
just like how yeah it's not how it goes
because there are a lot of women out
there on a date
quite a few actually i mean i'm actually
taking them on a date even in a
relationship no it's true even in
relationships
before prior to relationships i've
actually paid for dates and i'm like
you can't have to quantify so there's a
lot so that's what i'm asking like quite
a few yeah
like it's not with it your opinions
don't line up with like what we're like
talking about no it does no it don't
cause you're on there it does because
i'm saying i'm not i can't quantify how
because i don't even remember but i'm
saying there's actually quite a few
dates i've actually paid for like even
prior to a relationship with innovation
with those guys was it 50 50 the whole
time
no no
that's what i'm saying like like again
we're talking about okay you pulled out
your wallet here and there and that's
appreciated like a lot of girls you're
right like don't do that and i think but
but but it's still we're not asking for
equality here i'm no girl
you know
we're like on a date or something yeah
or like you're doing whatever it is i
like let's say you've done food drinks
like you're on third date now we're
saying so like you've done pay first day
don't pay the second day
pay for the pay for the third day now
now you move on to the next bar and
they're like
i'll give us a drink
what and then and then next is your turn
like they've got some four pound drink
up in tesco's and it's like yo i've
reached into my pocket now that's a joke
that's crazy it's a joke yeah like for
me but like again like for me that five
to one like i'm seeing that is the same
thing like yeah if you're talking like
and this
is question about stereotypes no but he
is like he's like no i should be paying
and i'm i'm
finding it hard because i'm such an
independent woman that i would always
pay
my in in different ways right and so
every guy you met like you on a date
like you would like your mindset it's
like
if i've asked you out on a date
i said yo do you want to go out how many
days do you ask out how do you want to
go out tonight you don't ask me
really and truly brilliant truly how
many first day i'm not about no yeah
like
maybe like four five four four four a
lifetime yeah four or five and i've paid
for from the rip that's what i'm saying
like if guys ask the girls going on a
date the number is way higher okay but
i'm just saying also it's hard women
aren't it's just a stereotype but when
do women ask men out on a date like i've
gone up to a guy in a bar and said
you're really cute and then i start
talking to him i'm confident a lot of
women are confident my thing is the
expectation like say i think a guy on a
date i would just rather like yo even if
you faking it like i can't afford this
date like just put the put something out
just don't just sit there looking stupid
no like [ __ ] like you know what i mean
just like put it out there like and as
is that if you've asked them on that
date you want them to still pull out nah
like a first date yes yeah yes
regardless who has who on the day
when the bill comes if you've not even
done like a courtesy lean
i will never speak to you again big
facts
no not for all i will never like the
girl i didn't like
what if she doesn't offer but she's very
thankful no
what does that mean bro
no i'm capable of life like what are we
talking about well because sometimes
like the guy will just like take out his
card but i'm always like like thank you
so much
like
like
don't even pay for it but that's what
i'm saying like like it's a test it's a
test for guys like yeah if the girl was
like didn't say nothing i never i will
never meet her again i'm sneakily paid
because i know he won't let me pay so i
need to go to the toilet and i'll sneak
a little bit like we said it's the um
what'd you call it the gesture like from
a guy's point of view but but we're kind
of going back back to the original
question like we have all these we have
we have a we have a [ __ ] march for women
oh well you've never heard of that that
much like that's so so we complain about
the double standard we have a slot of
like the the body count thing right like
that's a double standard and women will
complain and they'll go they'll like
like men have a higher body count they
don't get they don't get oh yeah like
yeah but women
yeah yeah and so
wow okay okay but i'm saying like like
so there are marches for that like we
have i don't know if you've heard of
this but there's like a [ __ ] march in
california
women will say oh let's